what's with the jeans hey this is red
band with death squad you're listening
to a episode of your mom's house with
Tom Segura he's on the road in Australia
and he's been doing a bunch of podcasts
all the way out there and if you want to
listen to all these podcasts your my
mom's house you can always go to death
squad TV and see all the video
components - all the podcasts all the
links to all the guests
now with that Tom Segura is he's not
gonna have any video because he's
somewhere overseas somewhere so but
check out all the other podcasts we do
you could also go on iTunes and
subscribe to death squad
and we want to thank everyone for all
your donations that are helping us with
our server issues we've been switching
servers we I'm about to switch it for
the third time so I just we're getting
too too busy all right or we're getting
too popular and so it's getting kind of
crazy but guys thanks for listening and
now here's an episode of your mom's
house and we're on welcome to another
mom cast your mom's house down under
Australian audition there's only one mom
here Tom because Christina didn't come
to Australia but I am joined by my
fellow partner in crime for two weeks in
Australia wonderfully talented hilarious
Hannibal Buress Haydn Hannibal I'm doing
all right Tom thank you for joining me
thanks in my no problem and I'm glad
that you like the mom cast you're in our
new high-tech studio yeah let's see I
setup I open that curtain just for you
by the way so you have something nice to
look at check out the view I got for you
yeah and we just came from the Melbourne
aquarium where they had I don't know
they had kind of a an underwhelming
exhibit would you say in a way it was
awesome but it wasn't
we paid $33 I don't think it was $33
awesome I think it was in the 12 to 15
range that's a great assessment and
as you noted I think as we were walking
through they opened the show to big man
they opened with their headlining act
you know they open with the Penguins and
you start out you see the Penguins and
they're great and then you see fish and
like bullshit fish - bullshit fish and
some good fish but that's still they
have a different look the Penguins are
doing stuff to fish a homely swimming so
yeah I think that was that's a horrible
setup on their part because you kind of
bombed out just looking at fish but then
they do closed out nicely with the
sharks but I gotta say the shark exhibit
for me was a bit of a letdown I was
expecting some fucking monsters you know
I wanted to see like great whites and
hammerheads and shit but I mean it was
cool the way it was set up but I wanted
to see bigger crazier sharks I think we
might have missed we should we should
have timed it out to get there for
feeding time yeah have you got to see
the pink was good friend and that was
really cool
yeah I was radical and yes oh we should
have seen the shark fan well I wish
something would have went wrong and one
shark went crazy started eating all the
other fish yeah that would have been
great that would have been amazing what
is your assessment thus far of your time
here I mean you've never been to
Australia before right no like how you
what's your honest take on this country
or at least this city is it it's a fun
city when I've had a lot of fun here the
crowds have been really great I've been
eating a lot of food going out to eat
everything a lot been eating a lot and
ranking a lot drinking a lot but it's
been fun I'm happy that they brought me
over here to do comedy man it's nice
it's kind of crazy right that we we do a
thing where like there's someone on the
other side of the world it's like hey we
want you to do that that thing that you
do a fuckin 8,000 miles away will you
come and do that for us yeah you know I
mean it's nice it's a far cry from you
know paying to go on the stage yeah you
know I was doing that five years ago so
that's so insane let's go on now I want
to get like some Hannibal
background so that everybody understands
like the context of what were of who you
are and stuff so you are from Chicago
originally yeah Chicago and that's where
you started comedy
well my first time onstage is in my
college town which was Carbondale
Illinois how far is that from Chicago
five hour drive south of Chicago so you
graduate high school you go to
Carbondale College Southern Illinois
University's Carbondale okay you go to
Southern Illinois University what's
Southern Illinois University like it was
it's known for being a party school in
his uh it's a you know sort of in a
rural area is definitely a college town
is one of those cities yeah College is
the main part of the city and it brings
a lot of income to the city but it was
fun it's not the greatest school right
oh yeah just went to a school of people
I went to a school that nobody even
heard of man when I say my school is
that lenoir-rhyne College
sounds like a skin disease or something
that's in Hickory North Carolina it's a
liberal arts yeah yeah it's the only
school that accepted me that's not a
joke yeah really is well that you apply
UNC uh now fuck I wasn't gonna apply to
UNC yeah I don't know if girl no no I
was in high school in Florida okay I
wanted to get out of Florida I liked
that region so I applied to like South
Carolina
Clemson like those schools and they're
all like nah man nah I apply to
University of Miami you did solely
because of Will Smith song you're being
serious right now
Oh sounds dope I want to go to school
welcome to Miami needles so you're like
that's where I want to go that was one
of Mays
the places I thought there I thought to
Howard University did you get in the
Howard I got it to Howard and I was
gonna transfer to Clark Atlanta
University okay put it in I always
accept before a transfer out of the end
up Phillip hold on okay
want to make sure I'm doing this right
yeah yeah yeah all right so wait you you
applied the Howard you got into Howard
you were going to transfer to Howard or
no - no that was not flight they're out
of high school and what did what made
you not go it was I think it was the
loans like it would have cost way more
than going to a state school yeah far -
I mean from if you wanted to be near
home I don't know if they made it that
wasn't really an issue
it was the SIU thing was it was
partially a convenience thing because I
went to a program called future scholars
where you can kind of go to a college
campus and you after your junior or
senior year and take classes and kind of
get the college experience and I did
that both the years and so I had credits
going in - si you were you were you a
good student high school no I was awful
you were I test it really well but I was
an awful student I could have been a
bitch dude GPA was the worst but I had a
good a CT score the only kid I was had
the second lowest GPA in my graduating
high school class yeah and the only kid
with a lower GPA his real name was
Norbert man do you know if you're only
smarter than Norbert it's not a GPA
isn't a thing of smartness
no it's likes about responsibilities
ability and the time you put in which
mine was time management
yeah effort my effort was a dumb person
can get a really good GPA if they put
the effort in it go to all the classes
and work on it so I mean it looks better
to have a good GPA but whatever okay so
you go you go - what are you studying at
Southern Illinois initially business
administration but I wasn't taking those
classes yet they had this class finite
math which was really hard and you could
mastered I was a good regular math
student but finite may have seemed like
fake useless math yeah I can do you know
I could do math in my head really well
but that math did it I didn't see a use
for it and so that class was really hard
so I changed majors to what education
for a couple weeks within a couple weeks
I thought I wanted to be a teacher I was
17 18 yeah education and then maybe
undecided and then radio TV production
that's what I graduated with yeah yeah I
feel like that's a lot of comics to go
into communications yeah that was that
was good I didn't end up graduating I
just left school when did you leave
school four years after school but I
didn't have enough credits how far away
were you maybe another year think about
it yeah so at what point in college did
you like what year did you try first get
on stage
Oh - so that would be my goal was the
end of my sophomore year
oh and towards the end of your sophomore
year yeah what are you like 19 20 and
what like where's the gig or what's the
Open Mic the big muddy room in the
basement of the Student Center and that
shows there regularly yeah there shows
there they had a monthly open mic plus
sometimes when they bring a comedian
they would do that would that would be
the room they did like I saw a Kevin
Hart play that really when I was there
yeah oh wow bill burr played the good
comedians so you you do it once does
that like hook you or you like I'm gonna
give you pretty much how does that first
show go it was so so but is if you get
chuckles early on you just think that
that went great
ya know that that was that won't work in
a club right
you don't know the levels of laughs and
it's so if you get certain chuckles I
knew it didn't go great but it was
enough food for me at the time and then
do you quit school shortly thereafter to
do statement or no no I kept I stayed in
school I kept kind of doing it and then
one semester I had like failed out and
so like when you fail out you go to the
junior college yeah in uh in the town
like people in people's parents don't
know that you're in the or you're your
parent a lot of people's parents what
would know that they kids actually hit
me - you called
Wow so like cuz it does they don't it so
you can stay near where you went to
college yeah holy shit yeah a lot of
people would do that so you go - did
your parents know I think my parents
have originally found out but not right
away
but not right away no so you go to the
junior college for a semester get decent
grades and then go back into SIU Wow
yeah so you do that you do that I did
that then came back in sorta made an
effort at school again but not really I
guess I intended to and I just stopped
going to my classes or caring about them
and I was doing a lot of comedy and then
that was io4 and yeah so then you drop
out driver and you move back to the city
to Chicago's my folks place you do and
you start do starting with Mike's all
the time yeah and what are your parents
think of this like initially I didn't
know of course that would be different
if I graduated but they're like you're
kind of an asshole man like you dropped
out of school you you're doing open mics
now you're staying with us and you don't
have a job or degree but you is go for
yeah I guess that is not the thing for
you that's pretty incredible
yeah what did you get done with those
four years
ya know me but they're thinking like
yeah
yeah I mean I had what I think out at
about 85 credit hours all right so
you're pretty floral yeah so I mean but
yeah I fucked awful lot of time then I
look back I didn't really it wasn't yeah
those memories aren't that good yeah
yeah that was working that getting a
degree now kind of wished it with loans
on it yeah but loans lookup yeah the
long yes yeah they were only for a while
yeah yeah yeah yeah so now okay so you
you're home you're doing bunch open mics
when do you start to do like like when
you start getting paid gigs
it was spotty man I guess when I really
start featuring and getting some gigs
cuz I I was getting some stuff while I
was at school like small stuff
yeah like I went to this one Club it was
an awful club in Vincennes Indiana yeah
but that's a small little horrible job
but I was so excited to drive in a host
this boy I was like yeah I'm on a road
yeah apartment in Vincennes in the just
I called my brother like yeah man this
is yeah I remember I remember it I
remember em seeing a gig in Brea break
California Debray improv yeah and that
was fuckin like man that was like
Madison Square Garden for me I was like
ministers shit I'm getting $50 or 700
when I first started featuring at Zanies
in Chicago it was you couldn't tell me
anything I thought I was a headline I
might as well a big headline really did
you have a pretty big head about it I'm
a big head but I was just really I was
you know it was a big deal whenever I
always had a full week because then
you're not worried about the money you
you happy to get paid but you're not
like this is horrible
yeah this is great you're doing the same
as 9 shows Tuesday through Sunday one
day one show all the days except Friday
and Saturday two shells Friday three
shows Saturdays
doing shows and just you know excited to
me up there
were you like pretty like sure of
yourself but you kind of you really go I
know what I'm doing at some points I was
at some points I kind of yeah it depends
it dependent in a wave was and then at
this point you've already decided like
this is your career though right you've
already decided like I'm gonna do
stand-up or is it still kind of like you
know I'm doing stand-up because I like
it I'm getting some money but are you
still like thick I was pretty solid
you're all yeah I was all that so you're
doing this feat like you're doing
feature weekends and stuff then get it
scattered scat isn't that full-time do
you move to New York after you've been
headlining stuff or do you move to New
York as New York the first time in oh
six well you moved twice in New York
yeah was first well actually the first
time I kind of just came to New York
that's oh six yeah and what do you move
with where do you go to my sister's
place in without you know just popped up
you just showed up okay yeah I don't
know she's gonna say no you saw the way
around I just popped up in New York just
cuz I was that single-minded oh I was
like I gotta go to New York yeah and do
stand-up
my sister live in New York so I live in
New York Wow
she had a kid and a husband shit Jesus
man so wait so what part of New York is
is she in she's staying in Washington
Washington Heights okay it's in
Manhattan yeah yeah uptown yeah yeah so
you go what you get on a plane that's a
damn track it took Amtrak for Chicago
it's a Penn Station and then it went
from Penn Station with my luggage to an
open mic that was going on during a day
it was a Saturday and it was like
for four or five in the evening I went
to this over mic that I printed I print
out a list of different open mics and I
went straight to one with my luggage
shut up man
and then did you get on yeah got off
how'd it go went okay I guess and then
from there with my luggage I went to
this place sounds comedy hole yeah and
he's in LA now yeah and I did there open
mic and then they had it was still early
and then they had their regular shows
later
so I barked before a spot I won his
shows like passing out flyers and stuff
and it did a spot on the cloud show
before I even went to my sister's place
holy so you got in two sets before you
went three sets yeah so then you what
time is your final set basically over
where you decide I want to go to my
sister's now it was obnoxiously late it
was all bad I think it was like probably
midnight associate really so it was
awful so so you uh you do you show up is
she like what the fuck are you doing
here basically no she's pretty cool
husband was like he didn't say anything
to me but I know here like that at all
sure but I can even I mean right then I
didn't even I could even fathom that
like I couldn't even see how it was what
made you realize it like just getting
older like maturing you realized it like
that you're like were you like this that
was fucked up or whatever I mean I think
I rely a little bit after like they kick
me out after a couple weeks I'm related
in town and you got to go yeah and she
was like he gotta go yeah they didn't
let me stay at the place where they were
going and were you like upset about it
though I was bummed about it
riyo's really pissed yeah but they were
right yeah realize that they were right
or whatever I think it might have been
it might have been a couple years
and maybe even me having my own space
and stuff I can't pinpoint the exact
moment no I just think it's interesting
like in life I'm saying that we all have
had moments where like at the time
you're like you know you don't see it or
you're like what the fuck and then later
on you're like oh oh I fucked up like
you know you're like oh I was an asshole
actually yeah you know but like a lot of
times you don't realize it in the moment
I was like she's supposed to put me yeah
I'm supposed to be able to just pop up
I'm a little brother yeah that's good
just pop up in the town right right
right right so wait so those two weeks
go by and you do you go back to Chicago
no you just find places to crash hostels
fuck man
really yeah staying I stayed in a bunch
of different costumes I crashed on a
train a bunch I was legit homeless just
seriously didn't want to go back I
couldn't go back home right away just
out of pure pride
yeah and that one of the fucking crawl
back yeah yeah yeah cuz I made a big
deal about going to New York yeah I
can't I gotta stick it out and it was
you know stuff started how much of the
luggage did you have
I'm sorry going back to luggage but
wasn't that romantic and maybe a duffel
of stuff so at least you could is cut
out with half my stuff stashed in
different places like out you really
were like some people in like a street
dude like just crash like putting stuff
places and yeah I would leave my back
plate and then keep what I need it
with me like keep my backpack with me
full of stuff that I need it so how long
overall does this first New York run
last four months four months yeah
wow man and only two weeks so that was
at your sister's place two weeks my
sister's Jesus Christ men yeah hostels
and just fucking was crashing on the
train you crash trying a bunch
I remember once was a girl in New York
there was a friend of a friend like we
had our met we went back to her place
there's a few of us after a show
something we hang it her place was so
disgusting it was like the nastiest
place i've ever been in
was horrible and she offered me she
offered for me to crash that and I was
like no I would have slept on the train
what
that's how the nastier place was what
was it was there fucking shit on the
ground Scott
imagine how much will you be like nah
I'll go sleep on it strangers on the
public transportation instead of staying
your place that's hot nasty house shit
that's like a fucking sewage dump I
always had a thing you know people are
weird about like where they crash and
stuff I had a thing in high school where
if there was like I would be at a like a
friend's house party right house parties
were always big in high school where I
was and like they would be like we would
drink a lot you know we're under it 16
years old fucking hammered and then
they'd be like hey you can crash here
and I would always be like now yeah I
want to go home I wanna sleep in my bed
yeah and I would drive drunk as fuck
back to my place because I had like a
mental fix about not crashing yeah
somewhere else you know but what you're
talking about is obviously a heinous
fucking home that this person has this
smell the smells really awful just
disgusting I don't know where I would us
it's just it was it was really bad I'm
so blown away by your like dedication to
this right now
dedication to going after this to say
what observations on a Monday it's crazy
it's crazy I can do these jokes about
Nellie
I heard your rap stuff but I mean I'm
always done the video I'm not going to
give away your bits obviously but your
video
it is fantastic man it's really really
great
oh and I'm totally we're doing fucking
like 60 minutes right now like 20 lat
not literally but I'm doing the full
interview I realized yeah so the four
months passed you go back to Chicago and
I got while I was in New York I started
getting on shows and getting a little
bit of buzz and I booked new faces while
I was in New York
oh that's huge man yeah that's huge yeah
so that means that all your fucking
struggles at least had a huge redeeming
thing for you yeah and when you booked
new faces that must have you were
through the roof you had to be I was
really psyched I think I found out about
it while I was back in Chicago yeah I
did find out about it while I was back
in Chicago but see it was really
exciting yeah man come on so how far
into stand-up are you at this point I
was I was doing it for years that's
that's relatively early to get new faces
yeah that was the first time I'll dish
before they say people don't get it they
definitely don't know no it was really
weird one time where my last one I did
three like a to call back one initial
audition and two callbacks and I was at
the comic strip and a set of in really
well and there's all these managers like
yeah and then like after all that
industry bullshit like going to sleep on
the track wow man that's incredible man
this is like like like folklore right
like this is good like man you know
animal but dude sleep on the train
before like that seriously it's gonna be
the shit that people say so you uh I
don't glorify it at all because I could
have went home at any point my parents
are doing all right
like I didn't it was very it was a
business I could have tried to make up
my sit like I was holding a grudge at
that time a gesture I could have tried
to make up with her and crash at her
place it was all youthful silly pride
yeah yeah you make out with her since
yeah
so you you get your new faces
or you're back in Chicago yeah you do
new faces new faces this goes well for
you it went
I got management out of still with him
not with that manager but I'm with that
company now okay yeah one company three
yards
oh and so my manager was at three hours
left and then he wasn't really helping
me get stuff at all so I was like all
right I don't think I need a manager
we're all with three yards yeah I know
but he left three yards I'm saying it's
weird
oh yeah yeah it's not you and I'll emoji
most also trio's yeah
but not a good okay so you uh you go
your manager you get your manager
whatever and then how long do you stay
in Chicago before you try to go back to
New York again two more years so two
more years back in Chicago yeah and then
at this point does your like do you
really feel like your comedies building
and changing yeah
well that I doubt a little bit of TV I
did I did that Highland show I did they
date from Montreal I booked the the TV
show in Holland called the comedy
factory where they flew me out there and
did that you know six and I did Ferguson
you know seven so I was starting to get
some work I wasn't you know booked out
but I was getting some feature work and
then I was making trips to New York
while we'll come in do a week or two in
New York I'm just running around doing
spots then go back so I was starting to
you know be able to get traction in New
York in the end doing that was that
decided to make the move again so you
make them move again not one thing like
at what point like I've one of the
things I think about comics that like is
you know kind of like your your calling
card for a comic is that like the comic
was really developed has like a distinct
like style like there you can go like
you know you can listen to like I mean
any number of comics you could say Chris
Rock or you can say you know whatever
you could have said Mitch Hedberg
or you can say
I don't know Ellen or anybody like
there's just like a style and I feel
like you have your own style like your
delivery it's very much unique it's your
own right it's tant like it stands out
as your own did it take a while for that
to come out or were like do you think
like that you always tell jokes kind of
the way you do your jokes now or was
that more like a process yeah in a
similar I think a sister
yeah the way I do it now is just a
wonderful either way for me when I
started it's not much much different you
really like the even in the subject
matter like now it's just tired I'm I
delve deeper into stuff but I think it's
just similar like just lay back and
talking about stuff and your delivery
was always kind of yeah but it isn't it
Laidback yeah it's great it's great and
it's very distinct which is like a huge
thing I think you know like you don't
want to say like no one I don't think
Alyssa students like Italy sounds like
eight other guys you know I mean like
that's the one thing that no one can
take away from a comic is when they have
like a really unique way of delivering
their material you know so you go you go
back to New York and then this is like
what was 700 weight and how long are you
in New York before you book Fallon I
guess like two months so you doing a
bunch of shows are you working are you
working at a part-time job - or not not
working anymore just doing stand-up like
not like making a decent living like a
pay rent and I'm working a decent amount
doing colleges headline in some spots
and yeah okay so then you get you do
Fallon and that goes great for you yeah
you feel good about it that night right
you're like I was great great TV spot
and then what happens then a couple
weeks later I get a meeting with SNL and
they hired me to write when I said oh
then that's got okay that's got to be
when you think back to like going to New
York and sleeping on the train sometimes
right like I know not like you know you
had a choice you could have gone but
still yeah you were crashing on the
train and then you get hired by Saturday
Night Live yeah I mean that's the
opposite end of the spectrum right yeah
I think about the the sides of New York
that I've lived on and so yeah that is
definitely opposite are you like over
the moon about this shit like you must
be fucking psycho so I was really
psyched this is great you know and it's
gonna be really fun and I got a writing
job on the show and not just any show
like an iconic show yeah a weekly
paycheck what's funny is that I was
about to take like I had the SNL meeting
it was coming up but I had an offer to
write for this MTV pilot like some some
not that great and I was like ready to
take that sure because it was guaranteed
like a couple grand or something yeah
and I'm like let's just take this man
he's like take the S&L for me because
I'm thinking it's a general meeting and
now something where they talking about a
job I'm thinking it's just something
like I guess they want to just talk or
something yeah you know you have
somebody medes with you for sure hey
what's your story yeah yeah yeah yeah
but yes I was thinking us that but so I
went and did the meeting and yeah and
then as you know obviously you do that
for a year yeah it's a great experience
for you you're writing sketches every
week right yeah writing every week you
know just being a part of that live show
and learning that format and just being
able to work around everybody it was
really cool it was fun cuz I had a
couple people when I knew already that
were working in oh you did know people
there yeah Jenny slate John Mulaney had
already done about two shows with is it
an intimidating experience my experience
intimidating a like environment to go
into like it's so it's so such a bit
the most intimidating thing is that is
when you your pieces goal is in the
read-through and you're in the room and
everybody's got their scripts and your
pieces bomb and horribly and you can't
do anything about it because you
detached from its the actors they read
now yeah pieces doing bad
that's the worst that's like yeah it's
like you like when you when your piece
is coming up you see if you say your
pieces 3004 no yeah
it's like 28 or something yeah it gets
your piece fuck off man it's sweaters
like worse right and then the best
feeling has to be when your piece is
being read and people are laughing them
yeah I mean it's it was just really cool
I mean I didn't I didn't have many
things get on but I did have a handful
of things that did really well and read
through and yeah I was really cool yeah
the Katzman was coming up in there and i
was funny there like that anymore like
this bitch so that that what that was
for so how now you do this year then now
you change writing jobs yeah you go to
30 rock yeah how do you what how do you
could go from one of the other how does
that work like how did that happen for
you I don't really know uh-uh
I think somebody recommended me for it
and set up the meeting with them and is
your meeting with Tina I mean with Tina
and Robert Carlock
no that's and does that pitch to you
like as a general as well or it's oh no
that's that was literally immediate
about I knew that was about the job and
interview goes well goes well yeah and
then how long till you offer the job
there's a couple weeks or so and how is
that how is the experience writing on
that for you different than SNL them
it's totally different show up for a lot
of reasons it was different one is that
they were already working I think
they've been working a month or so maybe
more before I got there
who I was the only new person yes
Annelle that wood was like five or six
new writers so you asked like kind of a
shared experience with people where
you'd a new person but the format is
different but it's also more
collaborative and it's not that lone
wolf or pack of wolves type of thing yes
you working on something with something
you have to get that on it's more
everybody working on the script or in a
room talking together so you might say
some ideas somebody else might get
inspired by that idea now to get in the
script so it's more collaborative in
that way so yeah a very like like they
heard Tina and other people say this but
just the format themselves when in the
sketch you're trying to tell a story in
three or four minutes since this is just
one character and a main character you
just got to hiding it over that short
amount of time
whereas in sitcom you got to tell a
story over you know a thousand yeah an
arc for that episode and also yeah for
that season and for within the whole
show itself it's actually way more
difficult to put together that kind of
thing in a way right yeah yeah I mean
yeah it's definitely a tougher a tougher
thing to do the story they like breaking
story and and that was that was really
tough like sit in the room trying to
think of storylines especially for us
showed us already been on several
seasons yeah it's the stuff gonna go we
already did that or it's gonna give to
field like when you get hired do you go
did you go back and what start watching
episodes is that part of it or not watch
that yeah I watched most of the episodes
I'd already seen you know cuz I was a
fan of the show right so I saw most of
them but do you have we watched a bunch
yeah yeah like--on stuff that medicine
everything yeah uh and you also got to
be on camera with that you got yeah he
put me in a bunch of uh put me in five
episode what's your character it one
time I played a fake Tracy and four
times playing creepy homeless dude
so this art and would say oh that's
great man and now obviously you're doing
a lot of stand-up yeah you have an album
that came out called what my name is
Hannibal is Hannibal
any time I have the album oh I bought
the album thank ya man I put money in
your pocket money
yeah it's been fun man we've I mean back
to it now we got like that was quite a
bit of backstory but I want people to
know all about you
we've been having a blast here with
shows - yeah we have a fun fun gig it's
the three of its you myself and Moshe
kasher and we do 20 minutes but that's
in Australia they flies to do 20 minutes
X and we take turns in the rotation
every night one of us opens one of those
middles one of us closes but it's just
been really I mean the crowds you might
think the crowds here well we talked
about this one of the things is the
environment yeah there's no fucking
drinks being served drinks may serve
that definitely could peep so people are
focused on its own no check drop no
checks right and you don't hear a petty
conversation clanging drinks or or
really any heckling really no we've done
a bunch of shows at this point nobody's
out anything unless you kind of ask them
to yeah it's kind of like the most
desirable way to perform comedy right I
mean it's it's pretty amazing then I
don't know I I kind of wish that there
was a lot more of what we're seeing here
back home yeah so used to performing at
situate you don't realize how much of a
distraction just drink service could
because some people order their drinks
loud as hell so say now in a table where
the drinks are being ordered was
distracted somebody to the left and I'm
just here a little bit so they get out
of the show you know so it could
definitely change the dynamics and
sometimes - they're not trying to
distract you yeah but like you know you
could be in the
like so then I went down to that's and
you hear someone would be like now yeah
we'll have another one yeah one more of
these and you go hey man what the fuck
and they're like nah we're just trying
to order a drink like yeah but like
you're fucking everything up right like
it takes you out of what you're doing it
takes everybody out of what they're
doing you know it's it's a horrible
setup great I think that's a great way
to do it when I hear they do
intermissions after a couple yes that's
pretty cool too they have a way they
they have that I call it brackets and so
there's like a first second and third
bracket at the club's and what they'll
do is they'll have like three or four
comics on they each do like 10 15 minute
spots then there'll be a 15-minute
intermission people can go smoke they
can go take a leak they can do whatever
they want they can fucking leave and
then they come back they're like hey and
emissions about to wrap up people go
back see three more comics another break
it's a really good system it is because
it gives people a break they can go talk
about the comedy if they want and get
some more drinks and kind of get
relaxing it makes it you able to have a
longer show because of that I think some
comics in the states have really picked
up on that that environment is the way
to go because you'll see you're seeing a
lot of guys doing more like you know
rock club or small theatre venues the
ones that can yeah and that's basically
that environment where it's like people
are just listening to you yeah I've done
a couple just music venues Oh mom and
it's it's really nice because when you
do an ask those places if you're doing
comedy out of music venue you know those
people came specifically to see you yeah
it's not as nobody ran there was no way
who's going yeah I got free tickets yeah
absolutely
no bachelorette party is happen system
honey seat music we you know so you're
doing some of those now doing a couple
of those all right we're gonna I don't
want to make this thing too long but we
have a few more shows here is anything
you looking forward to do besides going
on yes I feel I got I should go stop for
my mom and some people back oh man
that's really thoughtful of you man yeah
I should definitely do that do you have
any idea what you're in his Jenner yes
aboriginal art really yeah why don't you
do some that original jokes tonight and
then YouTube yeah this is art do you uh
we always do what we got coming up you
well a he has an album if you if you
haven't heard Hannibal after I gave you
the inside the comic studio background
on him
he's really really fucking funny man
like really really funny one of the
funniest guys have seen and your album
is great so you should pick up a now
it's on iTunes but more importantly you
have a tour that kicks off I mean I
guess this is kind of far below yeah but
if you have a US tour that's it's legit
like a lot of dates yeah coming up we're
like the first few the first few is
Tallahassee Florida in a Boston as
Tallahassee is April 15 Boston April
22nd and in Portland Portland and uh
some LA dates Irvine and then I mean I
saw then it goes everywhere you're
you're really doing a bunch yeah doing a
bunch man and it's like three months of
touring
and it's what's the name of the tour
then my name is Hannibal Sora aka the
Hannibal Montana boy experience that's
phenomenal
and if you want to check out those dates
there on your website yeah which is
hobble Buress calm and that's Hannibal
the way you would spell Hannibal and
Burroughs is bu or e SS yes or Hannibal
Hannibal calm are you both yeah okay is
that a tumbler or something yeah all
right excellent let's see I'm going we
do a few more shows here Thursday oh
yeah we got four more shows in Australia
I go home Monday and I'm actually home
for like a week or two and then off to
the improv in Fort Lauderdale Florida
the at the Hard Rock Seminole casino and
then I'll have a couple other dates
posted in for for May on my website so
this has been great man thank you for
send down shadow thank you and we'll do
another bomb cast real soon all right
bye-bye Knights fosters